oh no way did you catch that I didn't catch
that did I miss that what is going on there
citizens of the reject Nation we are about
to watch from heavy spoilers The Last of
Us episode 1 Easter eggs and breakdown join
with me of course the man who's covering The
Last of Us series with me Andrew Gordon Twitter
Instagram agor711 who's got a firefly shirt today
yes I do shout out to the guy uh at Trader Joe's
before I came here recognized the shirt said to
me dude is that a last of a shirt and then
the cashier's like oh my God that's awesome
so apparently people want to be fireflies I
know that's the side you want to be on people
team happy all the way how many viewers do we
lose by saying that Paul one of my best mates
he actually encouraged the reaction to this and
I was like well yeah I was already gonna watch
it so might as well react to it on camera let's
see what details us Gamers missed over here you
excited Andrew I'm super excited anything last of
us leave a like people let's see what's going on
okay so the Last of Us episode one is now out and
I'm so excited to talk about it the first game is
my favorite of all time and I've bought the PS3
version the PS4 remaster and even the PS5 remake
that released a couple of months ago this is a
game I've completed numerous times on grounded
mode and the series is something I've been
desperate to do a deep dive on if you haven't
played it then don't worry because we won't be
spoiling what happens down the line as I want
you to enjoy the twists and turns as much as I
did on my first playthrough however I may need
to touch upon certain things due to characters
that get name dropped yet but I'll only bring
them up in our super spoiler section at the end of
the video which I'll give you a heads up on it I
can't wait I'm nice like that I don't like the
game the series starts off in 1968. originally
we watched as Sarah woke up in her bed and
ventured about the house but here they do
it differently rather than throwing us in at the
night of the outbreak we get some backstory that
wasn't even filled in in the source material the
game told us very little about the virus Beyond
being caused by cordyceps which had mutated to
infect humans these real-life fungi exist in the
jungle and the parasite infects insects and also
anthropods beginning in 1968 though we see a TV
show in which two scientists do a big deal time
about what the biggest threat to humanity is the
first one goes up about how we may have a pandemic
level event that's caused by a strain of influenza
which awkward now both games were made before the
pandemic and the creative team have retroactively
added this into the show to comment on it in my
opinion I think that's a great addition to have it
be included like the touch on global warming they
include the whole thing about a pandemic it makes
even the game in retrospect feel that much more
relevant and a little bit more Timeless in a way
the reason I liked it too is it just it fills in
some gaps even though like they go into a little
explanation there's some newspaper clippings in
the video game that explain a little bit about the
quarter steps and how it affects the brain but
like actually getting this full-on explanation
from John Hannah I say that right I love the
explanation it was really well delivered monologue
too but just again it fills in that Gap that now
when you play the video game you have more of a
backstory of how the quarter steps work and how
it can affect ants and that when it does hit the
human body how it takes time like yeah you know
you run from stage to Stage so I thought that was
a really nice addition designed his mentions how
airplanes are a new element that will help viruses
like this spread easier and later on we see
several planes flying overhead as Sarah Joel and
Tommy make their escape they add a lot of focus to
them during the truck scene and actually change up
how the crash happens originally it was caused
by another one hitting them but they do a fake
episode yeah I love that now the sign is played
by John Hannah talks about the threat of cordyceps
and how climate change could allow the fungi to
spread from the more tropical regions of the world
to human population centers he talks about how
cordyceps work and this is some yet the scientists
have studied in the wild the fungi infect their
host and they then fill them with hallucinations
that cause them to act a certain way a lot of the
time they'll get ants to climb high up into the
trees and then from here they'll kill the host
and get them to spread their spores one thing I
thought that was so creepy about the game is
that we'd often stumble across the infected
whilst they were unaware we were in the area you'd
often catch them subbing away in corners and the
creative team said it was horrendous being one of
them due to the parasite basically infecting your
brain similar to how the Spore ants were set up
in fact it would lay down somewhere and die and
they'd become points of infection that could fire
spores out into the air we see one of these later
on in the episode but they do stay their hand and
don't reveal the later stages of the infected in
this first entry the character also says this
very important line snow cures they don't exist
it's not even possible to make them that's why Ali
becomes so important later on because she seems
like the last how to dig Humanity out of this
hellhole they end this speech by clearly setting
up the stakes and showing why the world ends up
the way it does we lose that's another thing I
love about the game and whereas we normally watch
the outbreak and go from there we get a massive
time gem to see Humanity far far in the future
I actually didn't realize that they're saying
that there's no cure in the beginning that's a
perfect way to bookend the episode with revealing
that perhaps Ellie might be the Cure better
structuring because again in the video game
we only see Ellie when they meet Marlene and then
she takes them over to Ellie and then we find out
when she's infected like oh my God it doesn't
kind of click that she could be the cure for
mankind until a little bit later when they I mean
they do find out that she's infected and then she
shows them the mark but again we don't really get
to that reveal that you know what they're exactly
taking her over there for it it just it happens a
little later on yeah no I agree with you that was
a night definitely a nice bookend and I really
enjoyed that monologue we got from John Hannah
just again it set the stakes and just made you
understand like of Ellie's importance after this
we cut to the title sequence which is presented
in a similar way to the black and white one that
started up the game there's lots of symbolism
here with a fungus rising up to create a Skyline
showing how it's become the dominant force in the
world who wants to see one creating a face before
Bonnie settling on the silhouette sub Joe and
Ellie the theme tune used here is pulled directly
from the game and it instantly sets a tone of
solitarian Bleak storyline such a good song
so originally the game took place in 2013 which
just so happened to be the year of its release we
then got the 28 time Jump like what we have in the
show which took us to the air 2033 the game was
littered with calendars mocking the date and in
the second one you could even find a PlayStation
3 with a copy I would always find PS3 the series
changes things up 2003 we have the main parts
take place in 2023 we start off in 2003 and much
like how the game opens we see things from Sarah's
perspective now originally that had the player
waking up on the night of the outbreak which
also happened to be Joel's birthday yeah though we
get a full day in the life of Sarah and the entire
time I was wishing I could sit and watch this with
someone who had no idea about the games and be
like does he know Sarah is very much a reflection
of Ali they've even given her a backpack which
wasn't in the game to make her more closely
married to her she also wears a hurricane drops
t-shirt which Sarah two wore in the game yeah that
had the 2 2012 Tour whereas this is the O2 once
it doesn't mess too much with the timeline neat
little Easter egg on it is that all the locations
are so that are in the order of places that the
characters visit in the game oh that's so cool we
pick up the scene by starting at Sarah's window
and this is important iconography as an open
window is also Summit that's used on the game's
menu screen it also ties into something that we'll
talk about in the super spoiler section and this
window shot could become something defining down
the line on Sarah's room we see a band poster for
The Clash and also Destiny's Child this is similar
to her room in the game in which he had a halcon's
drop poster and also one for the in-universe movie
called dawn of the wolf Destiny's Child poster
says Survivor and it's not this child's Destiny
to be a Survivor oh no too soon too soon now
interestingly the calendar says August but we do
get a confirm later on that the outbreak happened
on September 26th because that's also Joel's
birthday she's just forgot to change it and that's
kind of some stuff like this to show she's just a
Carefree kid that's just so sad when you think
about it from Joel's perspective it's not only
the day he lost his daughter it's also the day of
the outbreak so every time there's the anniversary
of the outbreak this is his birthday that's so
horrible it's a terrible day to have your birthday
it's like people's birthday is like being on 9 11
or something that it would suck to have a birthday
on that day going into the the difference that
you know starting the video game The Night of the
outbreak from Sarah's perspective to spending the
whole day with Sarah getting to see the town like
literally like okay we're getting little hints
so that something's happening you know we see
the the market that's closing early or the where
she goes to get the watch fixed for her dad we see
there are little hints of what's to come so I love
how they again I liked it a little bit more here
just getting to spend one more normal day before
whatever what ends up happening just seeing it
from Sarah's perspective just because we we have
such a limited time it gets you more emotionally
invested in the characters even though it was
very sad what happens in the video game like
it seemed more sad here because we get to spend a
little more time with her yeah well you got to do
a little bit more in the show because you are not
being Sarah with holding a controller or you're
watching Sarah so that's why you have to do a
little bit more add-on I think it's great yeah
she was really good too now they also picked to
set it around summer because the heat would help
the spread of the cordyceps and it adds the idea
of the seasonal storyline that the last of us has
Joe says he's 36 making him 56 when we join him
later and over his left shoulder we can see a
football on the rack will not say soccer ball
your Chumps and this is actually an important
bit of iconography in the game Sarah plays soccer
celebrating her winning a trophy and the character
goes back and forth over whether to acknowledge
this or not we get a great catch down seeing when
we go to the news report on the radio we can see
a photo of them all together to the right of it
great catch you see Sarah moving about the house
you also get a good look at the football again
alongside an acoustic guitar on the other side
of the room Charles the king guitar player and
we learn in the game that he even wanted to become
a singer at some point in his early life however
he and his wife at Sarah when they were very young
and she ended up leaving him which is when it took
on the responsibility of raising her at this point
walks in Tommy played by Gabriel Luna he sounds
exactly like Tommy doesn't he does I actually
closed my eyes and couldn't tell the difference
definitely the same if I was having pancakes they
got no clue but we ain't the only town it's crazy
it's crazy due to a job he has to work a double
shift to get stuff finished for the day at this
point of news report goes out over the radio and
we hear a mention of Jakarta we don't know where
the outbreak originated from due to the game not
really telling us but it is possible that this is
the show filling in the backstory of how it came
about it's of course a very hot country and this
would tie back to the climate comments made by the
scientists earlier on Joe's t-shirts inside out
and I like how they have him done in the gray
one that he had at the start of the game this
is reflected in Tommy 2 who's wearing a summon I
want to say summon some ensured like how he does
in the intro now Sarah then goes to Joel's room
and takes his watch out the drawers so that she
can get it fixed in the game she just bought
him but here she's using his money to get it
fixed up because she's a cheapskate she's a bloody
Cheapskate a Joe's watch is extremely important as
it breaks on the night the infected rise up but
he keeps it with him as a Memento though he shuts
himself off from talking about Sarah there are
points where it can be seen longingly staring
at it as a reminder of what is Left Behind she
also finds a knife in his drawer hitting at him
potentially having a darker past and outside we
see that the truck has combat veteran on it and
from this it's possible that he might have been
part of Operation Desert Storm however this could
actually belong to Tommy as well as he's the one
driving it Captain Obvious here but bit of food
stuck it in quickly a Tommy did end up joining
the fireflies when it all went down and his
experience in the Army could have been the reason
why he got so high up in the ranks Joel says to
Marlene later that she turned his own brother
against him and we might see more of the group
from Tommy's perspective anyway that's enough
that would be really cool if we got an episode
that is all from because they're in the game you
don't you catch up with Tommy eventually you and
you learn like what he's been up to essentially
but we don't get to see any of the journey that
led to him and Joel dividing during this time of
the Apocalypse 20 years later absolutely there's
only some dialogue again not going to go into
spoilers here but there's only some dialogue
mentioned about what happened between Joel
and Tommy so uh yeah I agree with you just
seeing an episode that maybe focuses on Tommy's
perspective what led to their I guess you would
call Fallout where he ends up trying not to spoil
it where he ends up going to um just seeing like
what leads to that I think that would definitely
be interesting and again it's a different thing
that could be satisfying adds more to the mystery
that we didn't get answered in the video game now
when you play the video game go oh okay now that's
answered for me and the difference with this one
too is that it feels like almost Canon to the
game because of the fact that Neil druckman is
so heavily involved in it too you know yeah as
opposed to just being an adaptation it feels
like an expansion now we also meet the Neighbors
at this point and in the game this is where the
first infected attack from however it wasn't an
old lady and instead it was a man that attacked
them called Jimmy Cooper what's going on it's
Coopers something right with them I think there's
six oh my God a picture of George W bush who
would have been president at this time due to
him being in the job from 2001 to 2009. yeah we
can see the infection has started to hit Humanity
as we can catch a student twitching away which
we later see at the federal Camp is one of the
signs of infection the cordyceps attached to
someone's brain and hours which is why these
little mannerisms start before it takes control
I love the little detail as Sarah steps off the
bus and we can catch an advert for a Nokia 3310
which I think I probably had snake in 2003. snake
2 reigning Champion [__] you don't at me I love
it anyway Sarah gets the watch fixed and we start
to see that summing might be off due to the amount
of sirens and the fact the shop owners close up
have you seen the quiet place too I have not well
what's interesting is a quiet place was often
compared to sort of the tone and Vibe like the
whole atmosphere was sort of compared to the last
of us a quiet place part two has an opening that
shows you the day of the outbreak this felt like
oh almost kind of watching a quiet place part two
but a quiet place part two was first called told
that that was sort of taking inspiration for the
last of us as good as a cool like cyclical thing
I don't know I just thought about it if you guys
seen quiet place too you know what I'm talking
about they're likely making a run for it like we
see people doing later on and I I appreciate the
blind thing was a little clock face Sarah visits
her neighbors the adlers and she asks to borrow
the DVDs curtising by Patu Yep this is the film
not later popped up and The Last of Us Part Two
during a conversation has some big spoilers that
kind of Riff on this that I'll say for the super
spoiler section and I'll also go through what was
said in regards to the plot of the movie now Sarah
later gives this to Joel and the reviews say it's
one of the best performances I've ever seen little
little bit of a Funny Story here that always makes
me chuckle but Jonathan and Paul Ross both used to
be massive movie critics and they had a bet with
each other about who could get on the back of the
box for Batman Forever they both wrote really
stupid reviews and that's why the back of the
VHS tape for it has the quote from Jonathan
Ross saying one of the greatest movies ever
and the dog is acting strange too the dogs were
used by the bandits to show whether someone had
cordyceps or not as they of course didn't have the
fancy tag that the federal agents do now at this
point we get Jill and Sarah having a conversation
on the sofa which is pulled directly from the game
I think this is it's nice but I I think it's stuck
it's not what no no it's not sitting on different
sides what a change I don't hear anything did you
get the money for this where'd you get the money
for this drugs I sell hardcore drugs oh drugs
I saw hardcore drugs that's better when I do I
love how they do some of the stuff about him and
the father and daughter moment is the last real
conversation they have cut to Sarah asleep and
this plays out similar how it does in the game
only this time they make the pair a bit closer
by having her dude on his lap in the game I
don't think we found out why Joe left but we did
see texts on his phone asking where the hell is
PS5 if you want to see the phone call was learning
that one of the infected started attacking people
at the bar and Tommy got locked up for fighting
them she'll ask to bail him out and he put Sarah
to bed which is when we see her waking up which
is how the game properly starts as you see news
reports that are documenting some of the attacks
they have an explosion happen which then appears
on the news as well whereas here she's woken up by
the Sands of passing Choppers and Ducks the little
Pooch Murphy jumps up at the patio which I think
is playing on the dog we hear barking that we then
hear yelping as Sarah gets to the door what's up
oh yes yes oh yeah I remember oh Sarah visits the
atlas and here she finds that the elderly woman
is now up about and eating people I got a lot
of flashes here to the first zombie that you come
across in Resident Evil with the hair loss making
this appear really similar who've actually added
some into the affected yeah and we can see that
the cordyceps comes out of her mouth which wasn't
present in the game those were recorded sets I
thought that was hair that's what I thought too
I thought she was eating hair the whole time oh
that's just that's even worse oh my God whoa that
was a good science lesson we just got oh man that
is so gross in nature they try and get as high as
possible so they can spread the spores easier and
I'll love this addition to the infected that makes
them more horrifying Shaolin Tommy arrive with
shells swinging a wrench similar to how you use
melee weapons in the game they jump in the truck
and you'll love how we can see the atlas in the
street now showing how quick the infection spreads
the truck ride is really similar to it with a
being word for word at points okay yeah in one way
in the hospital which is the other and this is all
ripped right out of the sauce materials they head
towards the hospital and this is of course where
most of the outbreak would be at its worst due
to people being taken there after they got sick we
learned that the adults actually went there to get
medicine for the elderly one and this is likely
how she picked up the infection in the first place
anyway enough of me talking let's play the scene
side by side so you can see how close they are
some sort of parasite or something
there's some kind of parasite are we sick
no of course not are we sick no of course
not no cell phone no radio yeah we're doing
great a minute ago newsman wouldn't shut up cell
phone no radio and things man wouldn't shut up
that's Lewis's Farm
I hope that some [__] made it flip that
too it's on the right side it's Jimmy's Place
who do you think you're doing keep driving
I got a Kid Joe so do we we have room hey
someone else will come along [__] everybody had
the same [__] idea everyone and their mother
had the same damn idea it's crazy the attention
to detail no no no come on people move what are
they running from get us out of here let me try it
this is a great edit man after the truck's thrown
off the road Sarah's unable to walk and Joel
has to carry hair this is where we take control
of him in the game and it leads to them running
through a restaurant chased by the infected like
what we see here at this point we'll get what's
probably the most devastating part in the whole
story normally in post-apocalyptic Tales When
characters run into soldiers it's often a sign of
safety they're used as a way to show their people
of someone looking after them but here it's the
complete opposite order to shoot Joel and Sarah he
fires upon them and this ends up killing Sarah now
watch this scene a ton of times in the game and
it was only upon this watch too that I realized
that they did this because Cyril was injured
and they might have suspected a bite anyway
I'm going to show you how
it works alongside the game
that was different going the Tommy had too
move your hands big this is a
fantastic breakdown oh my God
I know baby don't know
this one you're gonna be okay baby stay with me
no I know I know I know I know it hurts
baby baby listen to me I gotta get you
up come on baby please I know baby I know
Sarah
come on baby girl come on
baby girl I gotta get you baby
don't do this to me babe don't do this to me um
completely gut-wrenching and it's the defining
mom and Joel's life that changes him for the
worse again the actors those scenes in the game
are so memorable gotta give credit to actors
when it doesn't feel like they're just doing
impersonations or just doing you know some type of
recreation like they're making it their own truly
secondly this is not even a nitpick or a criticism
whatsoever there's just one little detail that's
always stood out to me about what the game did
in that moment that I've preferred that versus
what the show did again not a criticism totally
love how to handle in the show when they do see
Sarah who's dying and then the camera doesn't cut
it pans over to Tommy and Tommy's like Joel
and then it pans back and you see she's dead
would I have liked that to be in the show sure
that to not have it cut back yeah I don't know
that's just something I want to point out that
I slightly prefer just if if it was in one take
like that it hits you a little bit harder yeah
I can totally feel it like it Harps more in the
moment they're both handled very very well done
but I thought he made a great point I mean I've
played the video game and I apologize to anyone
who thinks I'm I'm really stupid for not just
thinking about this in the moment the 50 million
times I played the video get the first game that
the soldier uh the reason he got the order to
kill Sarah or to shoot them was because Sarah
was injured and he mistook that for her being
you know possibly infected and I really never
put that together I just figured hey they don't
know who's infected so they're just they're gonna
just kill anyone in that area that's not what I
just figured but that makes even more sense it's
a great attention to detail the scene is the
key to understanding the character and it sets
up basically everything that's to come from here
we get a time Jump of 20 years and a big section
that wasn't in the game here we watch a child out
in the wilderness making their way to the federal
Camp which is located in Boston the red shirt
reminded me a lot of the girl in Schindler's
List that we see moving through the devil great
catch aside similar to what we see y'all doing
his role is also very similar to some characters
in the stand with there being Body Disposal Crews
that had to get rid of the dead after the world
had destabilized this child's found to be infected
and the federal soldiers end up euthanizing
them bedra is basically the remnants of the
federal government but they were seen as fascists
in The Last of Us Universe they had strict rules
that sends people to death for very very little
and in the game were first introduced to them
forcing people to their knees and shooting the
infected now because of their strict rule many
resistance groups rose up including the fireflies
several Rebels rose up and they propped up their
own leaders which if they were better or not is
another question entirely now I think here they're
painted down a better light and though they kill
the kid they do it mercifully and even lie to make
it seem like they're gonna be taking care of them
now what's very Bleak about the last of us is that
there's barely any kids in the entire thing most
of the people we follow are middle aged and as
they say children are our future the fact there's
so few kids shows how doomed human he is and Ali
represents not only the hope and the Cure but
also in the fact that children can make it in this
world that was one of my favorite details too Tess
is talking with you all later on and says that one
of the kids that beat me up they were born after
the outbreak like a big part of his their social
behavior they might not be as well equipped in
a lot of ways you know yeah because we're born
outbreak yeah yeah no it makes total sense and
we also see a poster that breaks down the full
time to infection and we can see that Ellie's
bite would be roughly two to eight hours with
one being on the foot giving someone a day one's
in the neck and face give someone 5 to 15 minutes
which explains why the atlas got up so quickly in
the truck scene interesting kids killed after the
scanner flashes red on them and this very much
foreshadows the Fate that would have come to Ali
had gel not saved her life yeah it's heartbreaking
because we don't really know what the Red symbol
means and part of me was hoping that the kid made
it out after the God said you're safe sadly though
we see her body in the back of a truck and this
is how I reintroduced to Joel and where he is
now carries the body almost like how he did
with Sarah and dumps him on the fire showing
no attachment at all at this point we see Russian
cards being handed out he's also appeared in the
game and they look identical to how they did in
that we then good shots of the city and also get
a curfew sign this pops up in the game as well and
it's identical to the one you see when you first
walk around Boston we see some of the citizens
and catch a guy in an Al Gore Lieberman campaign
chair from the 2000s election campaign don't know
why he's wearing this but they could possibly be
reminiscing about a world in which Gore was in
charge because because of all of his climate
change stuff or they might be the only clothes
they've been able to get a hold of in the last
20 years they probably haven't been reproducing
new clothes because they could cause dissent and
we see how people are hanged for leaving the QC
this is something that Joel does regularly and
he works as a Smuggler we catch a federal Soldier
twitching but it's not because it's infected and
you'll in fact ends up selling him pills in the
game this is something that Tess is coming back
from when we first meet air so I'll take one guess
the uh whole deal went South and the client made
up with our pills is that about right the guard
shows up later on when he catches them outside
and I love this addition to the series for when
he pops back up we pretty much don't spend any
time with the guards Beyond chucking them out in
the game and it shows how they're all working in
Shades of Gray with them wanting people to exit
the qz whilst also killing those that do he then
brings up the Firefly Attacks and these end up
bringing tests from her captives you see a big
bit of graffiti for the fireflies on the wall and
this is similar to the radio messages that Marlene
was putting out in the game remember when you're
lost in the darkness look for the light now from
here we jump to test in a moment that we weren't
really privy to in the game Abby's dead in that
we start with y'all waking up and she shows up
to the apartment beaten up after two people were
sent after her by Robert it turned out that Jill
and Tess had sold him some guns that the fireflies
also got here though it all centers around the
truck battery I actually prefer it with a battery
being something they can use to get a car to get
out of there and it kind of ties back to the the
backstory with Tommy Now They do change things
up from the game and the first part in the future
follows Joel and Tess as they hunt Robert down
eventually they catch and kill him which is when
Moline arrives and it's this that leads into the
early mission interestingly Marlene's played by
mil Dandridge who just so also happened to play
her in the game actually think that like them
cutting it out made sense story wise too because I
feel like they're more selective with the violence
here in the show just I'm getting that just from
the first episode that they're more selective with
their violence in the game it's almost as if they
set up that mission so you as a player can get
acquainted with how to shoot how to kill how to
melee and do all that stuff before getting into
like the real missions yeah so it seemed like it
was necessary for the gameplay but for the show
itself I guess we don't actually need this Robert
mission that they completely excised out yeah in
terms of servicing the story for the TV show and
then setting up the whole Tommy bit and like you
know for the car battery and all that no this
makes a lot more sense and there might be things
like in The Nine episodes we watch there might
be things like I wish they didn't you cut that
out or maybe I don't know I haven't obviously I
have not watched all nine episodes but I will say
that the choices that they made in episode one
thus far I was like okay I didn't mind that they
cut that out okay this was a nice addition okay
that was the right show I I just thought it was
flawlessly done the first episode now here we pick
up with test tied up and Robert begging her to let
things go it shows how much of a g she is and in
the game she killed the cactus herself the Firefly
explosion allows her to escape and this is riffing
on the scene in the game when they got across a
checkpoint and one blows off which makes Tess
and Joe flee through the tunnels now from here
we jump to Ellie chained up she's currently being
observed due to being bit and we see her standing
in front of a window again calling back to that
iconography naughty dog have added in their own
and shot at Easter egg and Ellie's wearing the
same [__] that Young Nathan Drake had on oh
no way did you catch that already catch that
I never played those games oh batteries full
he returned to the apartment why did I miss that
hearing Echoes of his brother screaming Joel Tommy
and Tess had to do horrendous things in order
to survive and we might even get the backstory
filled in beyond what we got in the game kurtigil
waking up which is where we pick up after the time
Jump and we see Tess telling him about Robert in
a scene that Echoes how we first meet it they man
up and decide to head out which is when we cut
to Marlene leader of fireflies we then see them
planning attacks with a map on the table a forces
is starting to ask questions about why people are
dying and why there's a random girl locked up
just down the hall Marlene is wearing clothes
similar to the game and they're planning to move
every Firefly out of the city because of Ellie's
immunity we even see one trying to recruit
Joel and I love how the fireflies are slotted
in almost every aspect of the city also worth
buying out the test is wearing the exact same
clothes that she hasn't in the game except for the
bandana which uh I like that button now when Joel
stands against his sleeves too you can also see
several posters including one in the bottom left
for Curtis Viper 2. at this point Marlene goes to
Ali and she throws her bag over this is exactly
the same as the game and it even has the little
Cyclops head like what the character has in that
you also see her pull out a Fleck knife which is
something that she uses throughout the original
work Molly gives her the keys to her handcuffs and
she brings up the Federal military school future
spoilers that will not spoil now but we will
talk about them later on in the video and how
this ties in a part of the story coming up now
it's sort of touched upon here but Marlene had
Ellie drafted into a fedra program as a child and
this was to keep it safe she knew her mother and
wanted her away from the fireflies and also brings
up Riley which we'll save that for later on anyway
she warns Ellie that she'll be killed that people
know about her and this comes to be true Jill and
Tess make their way through some buildings and
they move in the ground which is a similar thing
to what they did in the game now they come across
an infected person who's grown into the wall and
I absolutely love the look of this oh as it is
so good the more mutated ones that appear later
on everything that created immersion experience
green wool which looks like it's ripped right out
of the PlayStation classic when moving through
the tunnels you encounter someone stuck to your
wall and I was kind of hopping they pull out
the gas masks for this bit but unfortunately
they don't and those stuck into the wall would
attach and then fire spores in the environment
but sadly they cut that out here anyway it leads
them to the Firefly base which is where they find
Robert dead in the game it was Tess who shot him
but either way he gets capped in the same place
at this point they come across a wounded Marlene
similar The Source material and Ellie attempts to
attack Joel which is how she's first introduced in
the original work Jolin tessitas with transporting
Ellie to a bunch of fireflies and in exchange
they'll be given a whole truck they agree now
we get a scene in which they rest up in a room
whilst the rain Pours Down this is similar to how
it played out in the original with him all laying
low here for the first time and Joel getting some
should I Ellie finds code words and throughout
the game you'd often come across notes with crude
scribblings in them detailing things like safe
codes backstories and information about the groups
you didn't counter this is inside a billboard
book and it details how songs from each decade
detail whether there's a new stock in are the 80s
have a big X next to them and we learn that this
means danger this is very important as come the
end of the episode we hear a song detailing the
danger that they're heading into oh my God she's
open on the 1970s and at the top you can catch the
Long and Winding Road slash For You Blue released
by The Beatles this single had for you blue is the
B side to it and the long and Winding Road could
be a little nod to the big journey ahead of them
big reach oh that's not rich we'll talk about
more in the spoiler section I've been teasing
agile falls asleep and we get some repeated
lines from the game you mumble in your sleep
now that night they sneak through the streets and
I remember playing this and it being so intense as
the trucks moved past and spotlights rained down
outside the wall you sneak underground and then
pop up like what we see here and have to avoid
search lights as they pierce the surroundings
love the juxtaposition of a big sign that says
welcome which is of course something that the
Shadows of the federal soldiers completely
go against we then get this line from Ellie
actually outside holy [__] I'm actually outside
the ones that you ended up crawling through
at this point they come across the soldier
in the original they were caught by two in the
game Ali attacked them upon being scanned and
Joel and Tess jumped and shot them respectively
here though he gets a PTSD flashback of Sarah's
death which triggers him into attacking I actually
think this works better especially with a soldier
returning and it shows that Joel's even willing
to attack people they know if it rubs him the
wrong way well you see that's what I mean by the
additions and changes be specifically that like
those are just guards in the game but here
when they when I say like they're making the
violence count more that's what they're doing
they're making the deaths really count versus
you know just killing off some random people kind
of service Joel as a character yeah for sure and
in the game I would say just again Joel's a
character where he keeps things bottled in so
to actually see like the PTSD and the trauma of
what happened with Sarah like being let out and
then also having Ellie actually see the side
of Joel this early on in the relationship I
thought again very interesting choice like you
said it's IT services Joel's a character gives
him some interesting development to me comes off
as someone who's willing to do whatever it takes
to protect and also just the PTSD side of it
just what he's dealing with 20 years of living
with his daughter's death uh just again I loved
it the discovery is biting she says look look
this is three weeks old nobody lost more than
a day it's three weeks old no everyone turns I
actually like that delivery in the game though
[__] it's three weeks the alarm rings and the
group head through the fence which is when we cut
to the radio to hear the song never let me down
again by Depeche Mode it contains lyrics like I'm
taking a ride with my best friend sort of playing
into the show now this signals the incoming danger
as we watch the group head to the twins on the top
of this we hear the Cry of and infected and we
end the episode with a lingering shot on them now
we've hit that long-awaited super spoiler section
and from this point on we'll be covering things
from both games so if you haven't played them
then thanks for sticking with me I'll see you
next week you better be back mate you you promised
you would anyway yeah spoilers just just wait for
everyone to leave right okay they're gone now the
first point is Joel's guitar that we see in the
beginning of the episode this is how the second
game opens with him strumming away on it Turtles
had the second game ends with Ellie playing on
it too but she's enabled due to Hell losing her
fingers we also get a lingering shot of the window
to close the game out which is very reminiscent of
how the scene with Sarah opens him with the menu
now in the episode there's of course the mention
of Riley as well didn't want to spoil it for those
that didn't know but you're here now so you either
play the game or you don't care and this was the
girl that was with Ellie on the night that she got
bit this is all chronicled in the Left Behind DLC
which is basically to them all before she shipped
off with the fireflies the parent of kissing and
Riley agrees to stay but the piece is interrupted
by the infected who end up swarming the area Riley
dies and Ellie of course survives which he carries
a lot of guilt over now early on in the episode
the sinus talks about how the fungus devours
its host from the inside and where we look at the
clickers we can see the entire top part of their
head has been replaced by the fungi the scientist
also explains how she's a fungi being something
we use for penicillin but it can maintain a
host for a prolonged period of time in the
game we've caused meet the infected decades down
the line and we can see just how far they mutated
which is where I'm guessing they'll head
to after they meet Henry and Sam this was
the location they camped out at and
it's probably going to be somewhere
that appears later on the series along with
all the Riley stuff not really an Easter
egg but Sarah's played by Nico Parker
who's also the daughter of danry Newton
or gas masks in the series Neil drockman said
it's because if there were Sports in this world
they would spread everywhere and everyone would
have to wear masks all the time Fair Point that
kind of sucks as I love the aesthetic they
brought in the game and I I think people
could have suspended their disbelief well
probably not have even had that cross their
mind because we're living in a world of zombie
fungi wait there's gonna be no spores no spores
what yeah oh what a disappointment that's
disappointing that's such a signature motif
of the game and it's always so scary whenever
you just letting her like sportsmail like oh
[__] [__] it's about to go down and also
too I mean there are some reveals that happen
without masks so yeah I mean yeah I agree with
you that it is a little bit disappointing I can
understand their perspective Sports would be
everywhere so everyone would always have to I
can understand that perspective too I mean as long
as the show's good I mean that's one thing I'll be
willing to forgive possibly I gotta see the thing
but I agree with you it's definitely a little bit
sad that's the first piece of information I've
gotten about the show that made me go oh what a
day off besides Sarah to me it would have given
the infected encounters to sort of upside down
from stranger things feel but alas tis no more
now that's what Curtis invite but two this is
the movie that Joel and Sarah were gonna watch
together the night that she died he never got to
see it and in a bitter Twist of irony it's also
the movie that giola Nelly were going to watch
the night that he died too Joel and Ali had had a
falling out due to her discovering the truth but
she had decided to see if she could forgive him
buying buying him over to watch a movie that night
they were gonna watch it and here's what Ellie
had to say what movie you guys gonna watch what's
her uh Curtis and Viper too that's the
one that's been on my that's great oh wow
we used to watch these cheesy cheesy's
action movies he's really into them oh no
I actually really like them too what's Curtis and
Viper 2 about okay so two former Commandos that go
Rogue to fight bad guys and I think in this one
they go up against Russian spies or something
I'm more interested in this than I thought
I would be all right so the young one Viper
he's a trained ninja and he's a complete badass
so how old is he in the first movie uh 10. wait
how many movies did they make of this uh I think
they made four jeez you'll actually saw the last
one on the theater am I crazy yes yes lastly is
Bill and Frank the former of which we know will
be played by Nick Offerman he's someone Jill and
Tess have had a long-standing relationship with
and upon reaching him Jill and Ellie are escort to
a school in order to get a car battery they don't
get it but they do find Frank who discovered
was bit and he unalived himself which I have
to say because YouTube's been ridiculously
strict with the demonetization recently oh
yeah the pair will lovers but they grew apart and
Frank fled in order to get away from him anyway I
think that's all his spoilery strikes too and I
really hope that you enjoy the breakdown I had a
blast together and I'm so glad that HBO have done
Justice to the game I was worried they might mess
it up and though it's very it's very very early
days I think this first episode was great really
captures the feel of the source material and as
a fan I couldn't have asked for more obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on whether you
agree or not but for me yeah this was a great
way to start the series dude that was an amazing
breakdown very informative there were some science
things I learned like what we thought was hair
coming out of one one of the runners ended up
being actual notes it's it's quarter steps yeah
so I was like oh that's cool I'm gonna look at it
now as a little bit of Starship Troopers like the
brain bug when it's coming out like oh okay it's
preparing to attack with it that was gripping
I learned a lot it was edited really well there
are things I kind of forgot about yeah and also
too this this that one little Sarah detail of why
the soldier uh was given the order to shoot them
like I never even thought about that I played the
game a million times a lot of this one this is
amazing this is one of your best videos this is
an amazing ass video all right guys well subscribe
to heavy spoilers the king of breakdowns you can
subscribe to us as we uh continue our Last of
Us Journey John and Tara Erickson watching last
of us as well not having played the game so
getting two different kinds of reactions here
alrighty guys thank you for being here follow
Andrew on social media talk to you all soon